[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 le tour de l'actualité locale en
quelques minutes voici les titres de ce
mardi 24 novembre
les restos du coeur lancent aujourd'hui
leur 36e campagne d'hiver dans un
contexte particulier augmentation du
nombre de bénéficiaires ainsi que la
crise sanitaire et économique qui aurait
fait basculer selon plusieurs
associations 1 millions de français dans
la précarité
reportage à plaisir et invités emmanuel
nodé langlois président des restos du
coeur des yvelines emmanuel macron ce
qui s'exprime ce soir pourrait faire des
annonces sur la pratique sportive
l allocution sera suivie avec attention
par les acteurs du secteur et notamment
les propriétaires des salles de sport
elles sont pour la plupart fermés avec
le confinement mais certaines continuent
leurs activités pour accueillir des
adhérents unis d'une ordonnance médicale
et puis depuis le 16 novembre le salon
histoire de lire est ouvert à verse à
une édition 100% en ligne crise
sanitaire oblige des rencontres avec les
auteurs sont organisés en
visioconférence et vous le voyez
dimanche 1 c'était avec l'ancien premier
ministre alain juppé est la suite
également dans cette édition de notre
série de portraits est dédié aux
yvelinois qui continue le travail sur le
terrain pendant la crise sanitaire
rencontre ce soir avec le capitaine la
capitaine katia hamon un fermier au sein
des sapeurs pompiers des yvelines ce
sera à la fin de cette édition
[Musique]
et j'accueille sans plus tarder mon
invité dans cette édition c'était manuel
nodé langlois bonsoir président des
restos du coeur des yvelines alors la
36e campagne d'hiver je le disais dans
les titres a été lancée en ce mardi 24
novembre et ce dans un contexte de crise
sanitaire et des bénéficiaires de plus
en plus nombreux avec cette crise qui se
déroule alors comment votre association
s'adaptent à cette campagne d'hiver
particulière regarder ce sujet justin
brasier est allé ce matin dans le centre
des restos du coeur à plaisir 700 c'est
le nombre de repas distribués ce mardi
24 novembre par les restos du coeur de
plaisir la campagne d'hiver est donc
officiellement lancé
pour l'heure deux mille six cents repas
sont fournis par semaine pour 195
familles inscrites un nombre de
bénéficiaires qui pourrait augmenter
c'est toute une logistique derrière
justement pour les ramasse pour tous les
lundis ont fait l'approvisionnement du
centre du national parce que le national
des restos du coeur nous
on donne des dotations quand même parce
qu'on peut pas dire que des ramasse
cette année en raison de la crise
sanitaire l'organisation a dû être
adapté six familles sont accueillies par
quart d'heure pour limiter le contact
avec les personnes sur la matinée bain
on a des créneaux ont commencé à 8h30 et
on finit à 11h45
on avait un bénévole cap compagnie
chaque famille maintenant ballet
personne passe tout seul
nos bénévoles sont derrière les tables
pour donner ont donné du café jus
d'orange ou quoi que ce soit maintenant
on peut plus maillon essentiel des
associations les bénévoles ici au centre
de plaisir ils sont une trentaine à
tourner dans l'équipe pour continuer
d'aider malgré la crise sanitaire
je me suis engagé aux restos du coeur
parce que justement il ya ya ya ya des
besoins malheureusement il ya encore des
besoins et on aimerait bien que ça
diminue mais ça diminue pas c'est ça le
problème est donc on a besoin de nous
donc il faut participer lors de la
campagne d'été le centre des restos du
coeur de plaisir a enregistré 30 % de
fréquentation en plus par rapport à
l'année dernière
on l'entendait dans le sujet emmanuel
nodé langlois augmentation du nombre de
bénéficiaires à plaisir il vous le
disiez il ya quelques jours sur ce
plateau lors de la campagne d'été on
enregistre et des augmentations un peu
partout dans les yvelines + 43 % aux
mureaux + 18% en clavier + 24 % à
rambouillet ce que du coup en ce jour de
lancement vous êtes de nature inquiète
pour le lancement avec ce nombre de
bénéficiaires qui augmente et est-ce que
vous pensez que vous allez distribuer
encore plus que ces deux millions de
repas qui est la jauge habituelle pour
la campagne d'hiver des restos du coeur
dans les yvelines
alors je ne suis je ne suis pas
profondément inquiet mais je suis
réaliste donc de la campagne cette
nouvelle campagne des restos du coeur ne
va pas être identique au précédent
on entend parler de vague énorme qui va
arriver
moi je pense que j'aime bien la
comparaison qui est fait avec la marée
au bord de la mer il ya des petites
mares et puis il ya des grandes marées
donc je vois plus une grande marée
arriver
fin décembre et au mois de janvier parce
qu' un certain nombre de personnes
n'auront plus les aides sociales quête
dans l'hôtel pouvez bénéficier jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et d'autres automatiquement
elles seront appelées la nuit et si vous
constatez d'ores et déjà une
augmentation dans le nombre des inscrits
pour cette campagne d'hiver alors on
constate une augmentation du nombre des
inscrits là encore c'est pas ça dépend
descente alors il est vrai que les
inscriptions ont recommencé la semaine
dernière donc la visibilité que nous
avons aujourd'hui monde je dirais une
légère augmentation mais je pense qu'il
va aller de façon croissante au cours du
mois de décembre
et quel est le profil de ces
bénéficiaires ce qui a davantage
aujourd'hui de retraités et d'étudiants
c'est que les étudiants sont lourdement
touchée aussi par cette crise sanitaire
et puis cette crise et économique
absolument dans les retraités on en voit
on voit des étudiants parce que les eti
temps beaucoup avec des petits boulots
qui leur permettait de financer leur
loyer ou d'autres choses là aujourd'hui
non plus cette possibilité de petits
boulots donc ils font appel à nous on
commence à voir j12 exemple aujourd'hui
de personnes qui sont au chômage partiel
et qui sont venus s'inscrire parce que
ils ont ils ont des difficultés alors le
message que je voudrais passer là
maintenant qui nous paraît essentiel
on accueillera on accueillera tout le
monde avec on fera le maximum pour que
les gens se sentent bien aux restos du
coeur
si pour certains ça ne peut être que sur
si le besoin n'est que sur deux ou trois
mois
aucun problème on les accueillera avec
plaisir pendant deux ou trois mois si
hélas pour d'autres ça doit durer un peu
plus longtemps ça durera un peu plus
longtemps par contre on a pris les
dispositions pour que les gens soient
bien accueillis
c'est essentiel c'est ça on le voyait
les centres se sont sont adaptés il ya
notamment aussi une personne ça faut le
préciser au sein des restos du coeur des
mines qui est en charge de la sécurité
de l'hygiène
il ya cette crise sanitaire de
l'adaptation de votre côté absolument
donc là aussi
là je parle et pour les personnes que
nous allons recueillir et puis pour les
bénévoles parce que nous avons un grand
besoin de bénévoles
je tiens à les rassurer nous avons pris
toutes les dispositions pour que
l'accueil et la réception des gens se
passe dans les meilleures conditions
donc on respecte à la lettre les normes
d'hygiène et sanitaires
donc je pense que de ce côté là aucun
problème même si la dissolution doit
durer un peu plus longtemps que
d'habitude on respectera en priorité les
règles sanitaires de la priorité c'est
la santé des gens que nous accueillons
et la santé des bénévoles
on vous le disait augmentation du nombre
de bénéficiaires est ce que il ya tout
de même une note positive peut-être
est-ce que dans le même temps la
solidarité les dons continuent est ce
que ça ne baisse pas les ailes et dont
les les yvelinois sont toujours
solidaires alors complètement alors ce
qui est important à dire les restos du
coeur comme les autres asos qui s'occupe
de l'aide alimentaire on ira ira pas
tout seul donc les pouvoirs publics je
pense ont pris conscience de la gravité
quand même de la situation on a reçu des
aides substantielles de la part de la
préfecture des yvelines je les remercie
ça va nous aider je pense a passé la
campagne d'hiver mais on fait je fais là
profitent pour faire appel à des
sociétés dont peut-être dans le secteur
agroalimentaire on va avoir besoin donc
de d'aliments puisque la la ramasse dans
les grandes surfaces petites et moyennes
surfaces a tendance à diminuer donc la
ramasse simplement pour information
c'est des produits qui sont en limite de
consommation et qu'on récupère tous les
jours donc il va falloir de tout
l'écouté qu'on a cherché des produits
alimentaires un appel aussi à lancer
j'imagine aux bénévoles vous disiez sur
ce plateau il ya deux semaines qui est
une baisse à peu près de 25% des
bénévoles pour les restos du coeur des
yvelines c'est tout à fait ça lorsque je
le message que je souhaite faire passer
ce soir les bénévoles qui ne sont pas à
voir qu'ils sont qui ont pris un retrait
par rapport à l'activité à cause du coc
vide de 19
je ne les juge pas ils ont lu la sagesse
de se retirer lorsque la situation que
la situation sanitaire se sera améliorée
ils seront bien entendu les bienvenus et
je pompe sur eux et le site qui
s'affichent des restos du coeur des
yvelines pour prendre contact avec vous
merci emmanuel monnet langlois d'être
passé en plateau eh bien merci de
m'avoir athmouni président des restos du
coeur des yvelines et joueurs
cette campagne d'hiver 1 36e campagne
qui a des buts donc ce mardi
autre moment solidaire qui est lui en
approche et la collecte nationale des
banques alimentaires elle est programmée
du 27 au 29 novembre partout en france
plusieurs bénévoles 130000 très
exactement seront mobilisés dans les
magasins pour récolter des denrées les
dons sont également possibles ans sur un
site mon panier solidaires.org les
banques alimentaires font face à une
hausse de 20 à 25 % des demandes dead
mais dans le même temps aussi à une
baisse ils font face à une baisse des
stocks ces banques alimentaires ils font
face à une baisse des stocks
chaque année c'est l'équivalent de 23
millions de repas qui sont récoltées par
les banques alimentaires dans
l'actualité également c'est une prise de
parole attendu emmanuel macron doit
s'exprimer à ce soir à 20 heures dans
une allocution selon plusieurs sources
le président de la république devrait
annoncer quelques allègements du
confinement en cours réouverture des
commerces manne essentielle dès le 1er
décembre avec un protocole renforcé des
lieux de culte également avec une jauge
de 30 personnes est la règle et d une
heure un kilomètre pour les balades et
footing pourrait être aussi alléger le
chef d'état devrait en outre confirmé le
retour des jeunes dans les associations
sportives mais aussi de la pratique du
sport outdoor pas de réouverture des
salles de sport pour le moment pour
autant au programme certaines continuent
tout de même leur activité en ce moment
malgré le confinement pour accueillir
les sportifs de haut niveau et surtout
pour accueillir aussi des a's adhérents
muni d'une ordonnance médicale le
reportage à guyancourt de michael et
demi d'euros en plein confinement on
transpire dans cette salle de sport à
guyancourt
la structure est l'une des seules dans
les yvelines à rester ouvertes pendant
l'ensemble de la période
la raison elle peut accueillir des
sportifs de haut niveau et surtout des
adhérents présentant une ordonnance
médicale
c'est sur prescription médicale donc
c'est une prescription par un certificat
qui fait en fait office comme une
ordonnance la nécessité de faire du
sport alors comme je vous dis pour
diverses pathologies
ça peut être physique comme un mal de
dos un problème hypertension problème de
lombers etc ou un problème même mental
ça peut être un problème dépression
stress au travail on l'entend de plus en
plus à cause du confinement le
télétravail créé beaucoup de soucis et
ça peut être une pathologie qui donne
accès à notre club
au total plus de 100 personnes viennent
s'entraîner dans cette salle de sport
chaque semaine certains viennent presque
quotidiennement l'objectif c'est bien
sûr c'est pouvoir être beaucoup plus
sereine
psychologiquement ça fait du bien ça
détend après j'ai aussi moins un
objectif sportif donc j'ai besoin de
maintenir la pratique du sport
si je maintiens pas cette pratique de ce
sport là bas mon objectif sportif
forcément il est beaucoup plus compliqué
à atteindre je vais devoir faire comme
tout le monde
rester chez moi avec mes poèmes est à
terre mais bart et mes bouteilles d'eau
malgré six adhérents sion en donnant ce
la structure a vu sa fréquentation
baisser de 50%
personnellement mais pour moi c'est une
bonne chose parce que le sport c'est
bien aussi bien mentalement et
physiquement c'est hyper important
et pour moi avoir une activité sportive
physique quotidienne ça nous permet pas
de personnalité du militaire d'être bien
mieux dans sa tête
les salles des musculation attendent
maintenant les annonces du déconfinement
en bref la nouvelle maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire universitaire vient
d'ouvrir à montigny le bretonneux ce
mardi le maire laurin merker a remis les
clés aux professionnels de santé qui
seront présents sur place
ce nouveau centre ouvert depuis hier
lundi était en réflexion depuis près de
huit ans le bâtiment qui l'accueille a
été entièrement rénové un site de 800 m²
avec comme objectif d'attirer de
nouveaux médecins les propos recueillis
par astrid berges heures entre le moment
où nous avons commencé à travailler sur
le projet et cette ouverture qui vient
d'avoir lieu il y a dix nouveaux
praticiens qui sont venus entrer dans ce
projet donc dès l'ouverture de
l'équipement
l'objectif initial qui était de 2
de renouveler le personnel mais de
médecins puisque beaucoup de nos
médecins sont arrivés dans les années
fin 80 début 90 seront dans quelques
années à la retraite et voulait assurer
un renouvellement et bien dès
aujourd'hui cet objectif est atteint
c'est une étape obligatoire dans le
parcours d'un jeune de nationalité
française la journée de défense et de
citoyenneté a été suivie en 2019 par
huit cent mille personnes avec
l'épidémie de kobe 19 ce rendez vous se
tient cette année en ligne les
précisions dans ce sujet de mélanie
poker est la grande salle où se tient la
journée défense et citoyenneté est
actuellement bien vide depuis le 2
novembre dernier les jeunes ne sont plus
accueillis à la caserne d'artois de
versailles la gdc se fait en ligne
depuis le 23 novembre le jeune valet se
connecter il va remplir vérifier déjà
ces données administratives remplir un
questionnaire et ensuite sur donc à les
modules en ligne donc qui passe en
direct
et puis remplir à la fin questionnaire
de satisfaction de stars va donc le tout
qui dure à peu près deux heures elle les
agents prennent contact avec ceux qui
n'auraient pas fourni l'adresse mail
une fois convoqué les jeunes ont eu
chaud pour suivre la jdc une journée
obligatoire
c'est la troisième étape du parcours de
citoyenneté après l'enseignement de
défense qui est dévolue en classe de
troisième et de première et après le
recensement qui est à accomplir par les
jeunes en leur mairie de domicile entre
16 ans et 16 ans et trois mois
il s'agit d'essayer comporte trois
objectifs principaux
l'explication des enjeux de défense
la justification des enjeux de défense
puisque nous sommes le troisième poste
après le remboursement de la dette et
éducation nationale et enfin et surtout
l'enjeu de cohésion sociale par la
détection des jeunes qui sont dits
décrocheurs et chaque année 70 mille
jeunes suivent une journée défense et
citoyenneté au service national de
versailles
les journées en ligne se tiendront
jusqu'au 10 décembre prochain autre
événement contraint de se tenir en ligne
cette année c'est le salon histoire de
lire à versailles jusqu'au 28 novembre
des rencontres numériques sont organisés
avec les auteurs parmi ces auteurs
justement à un jeu
l'ancien premier ministre qui a
récemment signé un livre sur jacques
chirac
bixente mayence insisté ban et michael
et demi d'euros une année singulière
pour le salon histoire de lire de
versailles pour maintenir au maximum des
moments d'échangé de partage entre les
auteurs et leurs publics le matériel a
dû être adapté c'est donc un format
entièrement digitale qui a été mise en
place
alain juppé hauteur de mon chirac
ouvrage récapitulant la longue histoire
politique entre les deux hommes a
participé à cette édition 2020 citerai
soir participer même si cette
digitalement à celui de l'adversaire je
connais aussi le rayonnement jours et
surtout souhaité que le prochain qui ne
connaissent pas je rate une occasion
d'avoir 20 lui une image un peu
différents officiels pas toujours
bienveillants qui est parfois un peu
caricaturale les débats avec les
écrivains sont en direct sur les réseaux
et les livres dédicacés peuvent être
commandées avant et pendant le live un
contact minime entre l'auteur et son
public qui change de l'habituel
récemment venus est important parce que
c'est l'occasion d'établir également un
contact personnel avec elle aux lecteurs
toujours le temps de discuter longuement
hausse il ya une file de la personne
qu'il est de se faire dédicacer leurs
oranges mais là on a une phrase regard
c'est déjà quelque chose qui crée du
lien que lecteur je crois que c'est très
important
nous respectons plus si les mesures de
confinement mais est plus artificielle
est une alternative que les écrivains
adopte en espérant qu'elle soit de
courte durée
supporter assidu et si on n'a pas
d'autre solution et que le vaccin varié
malgré ces conditions bien particulières
les conférences ont lieu tous les jours
jusqu'au 28 novembre le salon d'histoire
de l'irs a également maintenu le prix
décernés aux meilleurs youtuber
d'histoire pour mettre en avant la
jeunesse et le digital
[Musique]
et pour clore ce journal la suite de
notre dossier de la rédaction toute
cette semaine nous vous proposons une
série de portraits d'yves illinois qui
contraignent qui continue le travail sur
le terrain pendant le confinement
rencontre ce soit avec le capitaine et
katia - elle est infirmière
sapeur-pompier professionnel dans les
yvelines ce portrait signé eléonore si
nokia
cela fait 20 ans qu'elle a choisi cette
voie katia hamon ou plutôt capitaine
katia hamon est infirmière sapeur
pompier professionnel au sein de la
caserne de saint germain en laye pour
elle ce métier était une évidence il ya
toujours que ce choix alors l'expliquer
c'est toujours assez compliqué il ya
toujours eu que ce choix je pense qu'on
devient infirmière canton à genoux donne
toujours cette qualité aux infirmiers
aux soignants aux soignants cette
qualité c'est l'empathie
je pense que tout soit nyon con qu'on
est de manière générale on a vraiment
cette ce besoin alors pas de sauver 1
ce côté sauveteurs il n'est pas du tout
pas du tout adapté au jeu de je le pense
mais c'est cette empathie
c'est cette envie d'être là pour les
gens qui ont besoin diplôme d'infirmière
en poche katia débute alors sa carrière
dans le milieu hospitalier
j'ai débuté en services d'urgence et de
ce mur donc c'est une bonne expérience
qui était indispensable pour être
aujourd'hui dans la fonction
opérationnelle que j'occupe ensuite j'ai
commencé en tant que volontaire à
l'infirmière volontaire je côtoyais de
manière très régulière des sapeurs
pompiers en intervention
un jour un poste se libère une
opportunité pour katia elle rejoint
alors les rangs des sapeurs pompiers
professionnels un nouveau défi cela fait
presque dix ans 12-7 parfait nous
faisons les visites médicales de tous
les sapeurs pompiers du département à
une fréquence qui réglemente et 1
nous agissons donc dans les médicale
urgente au quotidien et également dans
la partie soutien sanitaire opérationnel
c'est-à-dire dans des interventions à
grande dimension ouah dimension
spécifique auprès de nos sapeurs
pompiers la deuxième mission
opérationnelle
c'est l'officier santé au codis depuis
début février nous avons une salle
unique d'appel donc c'est la partie 18
on ne peut pas tout savoir on ne peut
pas tout à prendre et tout tout tout
connaître en une seule formation et
notre quotidien en fait c'est une c'est
une adaptation continuelle et j'apprends
toujours dans mon métier tous les jours
avec la crise sanitaire le quotidien de
katia a évidemment changé
une mission l'a particulièrement marqué
elle a collaboré avec l' agence
régionale de santé pour effectuer les
tests pcr dans les ehpad
durant le premier confinement le tout
début la mission je n'ai pas trop
dimensionné ça a pris énormément
d'ampleur parce qu'on s'est rendu compte
qu'on avait des personnes âgées qui
étaient enfermés dans leur chambre
alors c'est plus ou moins grand depuis
plusieurs moins et qui ne voyaient pas
leurs familles et même des soignants
venait très très peu puisque devait pas
du tout les exposer aux copines on avait
des personnes qu'on venait voir qu'ils
étaient mal an certaines fois c'était
d'une émotion mais terrible qu'il ya un
monsieur on leur disait on va vous faire
un test et puis ben après c'est en
faisant des résultats les portes vont
s'ouvrir vers l'extérieur
donc ça a été une mission un prenante
que pas par le temps mais vraiment par
l'émotion et par l'humain qu'on pouvait
rencontrer le capitaine a aussi
participé à la formation des chiens à
détecter le coc vide elle s'est occupée
de récupérer les prélèvements de sueur
dans les centres hospitaliers du
département d adaptation mais surtout de
la passion c'est ce qui anime le
capitaine katia âme
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal et on
se quitte sur cette belle image se
coucher de soleil avec un ciel couleur
feu aperçu ce soir à saint quentin en
yvelines
le journal revient dès demain mercredi
pour une nouvelle édition merci de votre
fidélité et très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]